JOANNA SMITH: This week, we're
talking about data discovery,
planning for your
Cloud migration,
and more ways to use Kubernetes.
I'm Joanna Smith, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud Data Catalog is now
available in public beta.
Data Catalog is a fully
managed data discovery
and metadata management
service, which
means you can use Data
Catalog to easily search
for tables in Google BigQuery
or topics in Cloud Pub/Sub.
You can even filter
for sensitive data
thanks to Data Catalog's
integration with Cloud Data
Loss Prevention.
Get searching, and
see for yourself.
Migration to the Cloud
unlocks some awesome benefits.
But wrapping your head
around the journey there
can be daunting.
To help you think through
the most important questions,
we've got an all-in-one
planning resource.
From assessing what to move
and why, to provisioning
and configuring the new
architecture you settle on,
no question is too
small for this guide.
Find a quiet nook
and get started.
Connecting to external
services on Kubernetes
has historically required
compromises, but no more
thanks to Workload Identity.
Workload Identity
creates a relationship
between Kubernetes service
accounts and Cloud IAM
so that you can
define which workloads
run as which identities, grant
access to other Cloud services,
and never worry about Kubernetes
secrets or IAM service account
keys again.
Try it on GCP today.
Running a database in a
distributed environment
can be challenging.
But if inherent benefits like
rapid spin-up and repeatability
keep calling your name,
this blog is for you.
In it, we'll explore
what types of databases
can be effectively run
on Kubernetes, when it
makes the most sense, and why.
Make an informed
decision about where
to run your databases with
this fast read on the GCP blog.
Now, if you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
And we'll see you in the Cloud.